que faire des cabines téléphoniques
autrefois il fallait attendre patiemment
son tour parfois très longtemps même
pour finalement se rendre compte qu'on
n'avait pas assez de monnaie pour
finalement les utiliser ces cabines
téléphoniques aujourd'hui il est surtout
très difficile d'en trouver une et
quelles sont les pistes pour les
recycler avant d'en parler avec valérie
beau pour la chronique de
l'environnement et avec ses invités
c'est vous qui avez la parole quelles
sont vos idées vos pistes pour les
recycler ces fameuses cabine je pense à
doit se trier tout ce qui est faire d'un
côté plastique de l'autre côté donc je
pense en déchetterie ça peut être
recyclé quoi on n'en a plus besoin
aujourd'hui tout le monde a un portable
à la preuve donc je pense qu'on peut les
recycler maintenant ce n'est pas tout
les supprimer ça serait tendu ça sera un
billet parce que tout le monde n'a pas
forcément un portable peut-être pour du
design pourquoi pas créer créer des
comment dire des
des oeuvres faut pas oublier quand même
que ça fait partie de notre vie et voilà
ça peut faire un beau décor dans les
jardins un petit peu comme les anglais
là vous les payez en rouge ou avec des
couleurs sympa pour les jeunes et ça
fait une petite cabane de jardin
à l'environnement comme chaque semaine
avec valérie valérie aujourd'hui nous
allons parler en ce 18 décembre de ces
cabines téléphoniques qui peuvent avoir
une deuxième vie oui tout à fait elles
sont encore 125000 dans nos rues un peu
plus sain et avec 580 à 125 1155
exactement c'est comme si avec
l'avènement des téléphones mobiles elles
sont de moins en moins utilisé mais les
cabines téléphoniques pourrait bientôt
connaître une seconde vie être recyclés
en bibliothèque dans les lycées c'est le
concept biblio box in aussi initié par
la maison de l'europe pour en parler
avec nous regina le coin de mon soir et
isabelle de save au soir de ce web de
l'opérateur orange la première bible au
box a été inaugurée le 29 novembre
dernier au lycée adrian bolland à poissy
et nous allons voir de suite de quoi il
s'agit avec les images de guillaume
cambis
choisir son livre non pas à la
bibliothèque mais dans une cabine
téléphonique
c'est le concept biblio boxe inaugurée
en france en novembre dernier dans le
lycée de poissy l'idée a été lancée par
la maison de l'europe avec des premiers
essais concluants il y a deux mois à
berne c'est un peu un projet atypique
parce qu'au départ quand on a exposé
transformer une cabine téléphonique en
bibliothèque y avait des gens qui n'ont
gardé un peu de façon tiens c'est un peu
marginal un peu insolite et puis petit à
petit ils ont compris que le projet
était quand même d'une belle qualité
donc pour nos jeunes c'est
extraordinaire je pense qu'ils vont
vraiment en retirer belle leçon de vie
de d'échangés de tolérance aussi parce
qu'ils vont voir leurs esprits ça va
leur faire du bien
le projet culturel éducatif mais aussi
pédagogique a reçu le concours de
l'académie de versailles
l'opérateur de téléphonie orange donne
ses cabines téléphoniques obsolète qui
jouissent ainsi d'une seconde vie
mentant prof d'allemand ça m'intéressait
énormément puisque c'étaient les
relations franco allemandes et puis mes
collègues étaient partants aussi de nos
collègues d' ateliers d'ébénisterie
d'art et les élèves aussi donc du coup
nous paraissait judicieux de faire cet
échange est ce plot projet la
présentation de la première biblioblog
française est aussi l'occasion
d'échanger avec nos voisins allemands
qui avaient fait le voyage jusqu'à
poissy d'ici peu ce sera au tour des
lycéens yvelinois de ces journées
outre-rhin pour patrice ce sera la
troisième fois on va aller dans un lycée
à berlin et après on en entreprise
et en fait c'est pour ça que qu'on nous
propose ce projet en même temps qu'on
nous a parlé de ce projet à ce jour six
établissements de l'académie de
versailles participent à ce projet
donc regina lecointe c'est la fin des
bibliothécaires des grandes
bibliothèques dans les lycées non pas du
tout et un autre projet c'est un autre
but
avec ses billes dans les
établissements alors y'a 2 de recyclage
il ya le recyclage de la cabine mais
aussi des livres quand tu commences se
situe ce concept et j'ai l'habitude de
dire que c'est un
projet à poupée russe pour commencer à
ouvrir il a il ya plein d'autres choses
qui en sortent et c'est également pour
la première bibliothèque ce parce que
vous avez d'abord la construction le
recyclage de la cabine pour la
transformer en bibliothèque de rue voilà
et après vous avez lusage la cabine et
ça ça dépend après vous vous la mettez
si vous la mettez dans un espace public
ou si vous la mettez dans un dans une
cour d'école car alors là ça va être le
cas et avec des livres
donc ce sont des non pas 9 non non non
parce que la grande davis et celle ci
apporte en livre prend un livre lit en
livre donc c'est un ancien on citera que
ce soit des professeurs que ce soit les
élèves du moment ça sera dans une cour
d'école d'apporter des livres qu'ils ont
bien aimé mais qui pour des raisons d
espaces parce qu'ils en ont d'autres il
faut bien faire un petit tri qu'ils
emmènent parce qu'ils veulent pas
j'étais mettra au 6 rue de la mer mettre
le livre à la poubelle c'est de le
libérer en quelque sorte mettre dans la
cabine pour donner accès à d'autres à ce
livre donc ce sont les professeurs qui
gére où ces bibliothèques ça après c'est
l'établissement scolaire qui décident
parce qu'il faut quand même impliquer
les élèves dans ce projet là je vous
disais que les professeurs
ça n'a pas d'intérêt mais c'est sûr que
c'est un formidable outil pédagogique
qui peut et est réutilisé par les
professeurs par les élèves vous pouvez
organiser autour que ce soit la journée
de l'europe ça ne concerne que ça soit
la journée franco-allemande la journée
de la femme ou tout ce que vous voulez
aimez vous pouvez aussi les élèves
peuvent comprendre dans l'est la récré
peuvent prendre en libre s'installer
lire ou feuilleter regarde et discuter
avec les autres mais a battu prend celui
là tiens celui là il est intéressant je
l'avais déjà lui donc il ya plein de
choses c'est aussi pour être en lien
social pour que les jeunes se parle
aussi pour les maintenant on parle
beaucoup des livres électroniques
là c'est un petit peu de les ramener
d'une façon à vendre différents vers la
lecture des reprendre en livre parce que
c'est aussi
en écran c'est c'est froid est ce qu'un
livre c'est on a une relation avec un
livre je tire presque une relation
essentielle donc ça montre simplement la
lecture est aussi la barre en main d
la mener dans les rer et sera donc donc
voilà aussi de retrouver le livre et la
relation avec les livres et avec
l'écriture même si la biblio box pour
beaucoup plus de place qu'une petite
tablette ou une liseuse électronique
mais c'est pas celui qui ce soir c'est
sûr c'était juste pour pour la boutade
je suis convaincu de l'intérêt du livre
par rapport à la tablette avait pas
besoin de me convaincre au delà tout ça
vous avez inauguré la donc du côté de
poissy 7 biblioblog ce passé l'effet de
surprise les jeunes nous ont accueillis
comment ils se sont déjà approprié
l'objet à oui oui à dégager les ai vus
et d'ailleurs cct est et le lancement on
va être clair parce que c'est le
lancement la cabine allemande de berlin
est arrivé et la cabine parisienne et
elle est partie à berlin donc c'était
déjà cet échange là parce que ça
présente aussi en échange culturel dans
ce cadre là et évidemment les les élèves
se sont appropriés ont déjà beaucoup
d'idées avec les professeurs on a une
équipe fantastique
pédagogique apprécié au lycée adrienne
bolland donc ils sont très très preneur
et puisqu'ils sont des ébénistes et j'ai
appris quelque chose que je ne savais
pas c'est qu'à la cour de louis xiv il y
avait beaucoup de débit nist d'origine
allemand quittez là donc ils séparent à
travers deux
de ça que les ébénistes veulent montrer
la relation franco allemande ont ils ont
déjà plein d'idées et puisque la cabine
doit en principe aller au rectorat de
versailles dont personne ça
évidemment l'ébénisterie me disant des
idées mais ils vont à berlin ils vont
discuter avec l'équipe allemande parce
que c'est quand même une coopération
franco-allemande donc ils discuteront
avec les allemands ce qu'ils ont fait
déjà fait des deux jeunes filles qui
étaient là alors justement vous parliez
du rectorat vous avez de nombreux
partenaires notamment l'académie de
versailles mais aussi orange
l'opérateur
il avait des seuils qu'est ce qui vous a
convaincu de vous orienter dans ce
projet est de mettre à disposition car
ce sont des dons ces cabines
téléphoniques
l'extraordinaire motivations de régis
90 voilà qui est très convaincante donc
on s'est rencontré il ya quelques années
au tour d'un autre projet et
les équipes ont discuté ensemble avec la
maison de l'europe et on a trouvé que
c'était un très joli projet ça a été un
projet coup de coeur pour nous voilà ça
arrive on est vraiment à une politique
environnementale impulsée par orange
déjà voilà alors depuis très longtemps
orange a mis en place une politique de
protection de l'environnement on a une
responsabilité
très grande puisqu'on vend des terminaux
téléphoniques on vend des tablettes on
vend voilà et et on doit s'assurer que
l'ensemble de ces objets va pouvoir
avoir une deuxième vie dans des
conditions qui sont économiquement et
socialement responsable donc on est très
très attentif à ce sujet là par exemple
depuis un an on a proposé à l'essentiel
de nos clients de supprimer leurs
factures papier et on a donc de ce fait
économiser y ait plus d'un millier de
tonnes de papier en les faisant
bénéficier de factures électroniques
tout simplement donc on fait de
nombreuses on mène de nombreuses actions
dans le domaine du développement durable
et là les cabines téléphoniques qui ne
sont pas utilisés pour cette opération
du duo box elles deviennent quoi alors
on a un sous traitant qui
avec lequel on travaille depuis depuis
très longtemps que la société qui est la
société véolia et donc on
recycle et on récupère d'une part les
habitacles et d'autre part tout ce qui
est à l'intérieur de ses habitacles donc
le tour aussi les puces tout bien pensé
à l'époque tout est recyclé tout est
recyclable et ça nous permet d'ailleurs
d'entretenir les cabines qui sont
évidemment elle toujours incertain je
demande et ça permet de faire de la
maintenance sur les cabines existantes
pour les 125
0,325 j'entrerai
en à 1375 dans les yvelines
c'est la question du jour devant
l'émission valérie vous ne saviez pas
mais pas là et donc elles sont
démantelés avant d'être mise à
disposition de la maison de l'europe et
des délices et comment ça se passe on ne
donne à la maison d'enfants aux écoles
on donne l'habitacle donc effectivement
on enlève tout ce qui est à l'intérieur
qui peut être dangereux l'énergie les
combinés et c'est donc on donne les
enfants les adolescents on leur confie
cet habitacle simplement voit qu'ils
vont relooké à leur goût ensuite les
ébénistes notamment au
plan corps de métiers que ce soit d'être
le lac pour
l'ébénisterie que ce soit aussi propre
le métal donc il ya ça aussi c'est le
côté intéressant c'est entre 10 et
disciplinaires des jeunes doivent les
différentes filières doivent travailler
ensemble donc là aussi c'est un aperçu
déjà de ce que ça peut donner de
travailler en entreprise où on n'est pas
que dans son petit coin pour des
commandes qui arrivent et où il faut
travailler avec
d'autres métiers donc ça aussi c'est ce
côté très intéressant très pédagogique
qui qui m'avait séduit quand j'ai les ai
découverts à berlin d'accord et donc
vous avez fait don de quatre autres
cabine qui seront installés dans quatre
autres lycées de l'île de france
exactement qui va subir le même
traitement
qu'à une cabine téléphonique c'est
formidable merci à tous les deux d'être
venu sur le plateau valérie ont
poursuivi ces chroniques environnement
un petit agenda peut-être quelques
instants passion une boutique cuisine ou
a ouvert ses portes depuis le 30
novembre à la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines twizy ouais je rappelle c'est
ce concept d'autopartage initié par la
communauté d'agglo de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et par run ou
deux autres informations la première
c'est pour la ville de coignières oui la
ville de coignières et lauréate du
trophée de la mise en valeur des
équipements publics par le fleurissement
un prix décerné par le conseil général
des yvelines dans le cadre du concours
des villes et villages fleuris 2012 et
puis après le renouvellement du marché
public des différentes collectes sur la
ville de voisins-le-bretonneux la
cadence de ramassage des déchets verts
est modifié pour décembre alors décembre
c'est c'est presque passé janvier et
février durant cette perte cette période
la collecte ne s'effectuera plus qu'une
seule fois par mois chaque deuxième
lundi du mois ces déchets sont à déposer
la veille au soir après 18 heures dans
les sacs végétaux prévu il reste encore
quelques jours pour le mois de décembre
tout de même si vous êtes concerné
termine avec la maison de
l'environnement oui la maison de
l'environnement qui propose les 19 26 et
27 décembre un atelier pour petits et
grands la coopération késako l'occasion
de découvrir grâce à des jeux
interactifs
l'apprentissage de la citoyenneté et des
valeurs du faire ensemble pour réussir
merci valérie rendez vous en janvier
pour la prochaine chronique de
l'environnement puisque la semaine
prochaine sur tv fils une série de cinq
éditions spéciales seront à découvrir
je vous donnerai plus d'informations
d'ici la fin de la semaine de fête de
noël à plaisir en un seul week-end la
lune était organisée par la municipalité
l'autre par l'association des résidants
des gâtines deux ambiances et un thème
commun le champ regardez
ah
oui
ce week end à plaisir c'était noël avant
l'heure pour l'association des gâtines
pêche à la ligne atelier biscuits
décorations pour le sapin les enfants
étaient à l'honneur j'ai fait
un bonhomme de neige en sus klaba
et gâteaux sucrés
et on pêche est là et là j'ai fait mes
cheveux j'ai fait la canne à pêche moi
je vais m'occuper du stand gâteau et on
s'est relayé avec les mamans alors
chacun participe à un petit peu ça fait
quelque chose de sympa noël c'est la
fête des enfants auparavant et quelques
années on faisait un marché de noël et
puis on s'est dit que finalement il
fallait avoir quelque chose qui était
beaucoup plus orienté vers les enfants
donc on a décidé de faire une fête de
noël donc avec des ateliers dédiés aux
enfants donc c'est la troisième édition
cette année grande nouveauté 70 écoliers
chante sur scène ils se tiennent bien
pour cette venue
c'est qu'on va chanter ensemble de
petits bobos noël noël blanc nos mains
et quelque chose de rejouer ce rappel et
la fibre artistique semble avoir touché
des enfants de l'école de théâtre de la
ville qui pour leur spectacle de noël se
sont essayés au chant sur scène trente
musiciens ont accompagné 23 enfants
l'histoire reprend des des légendes
bretonnes quelque part et qui est l'idée
c'était de mettre des enfants sur scène
avec un orchestre professionnel derrière
et tout en dotant aussi de costumes par
des professionnels et aussi d'un design
de costumes par un professionnel qui a
un illustrateur breton d'ailleurs soit
en effet guy sont faits graves et
comment chante pas tous la même chose
certains font grève d'autres aiguë faire
attention à ne pas assimiler les
pinceaux c'est ma cinquième année de
théâtre dont je suis habitué à la scène
mais le champ non plus c'est pas gênant
c'est en place les sciences a été
adaptée quand je chantais grave donc
cette année vous l'aurez compris le
champ accompagnera les fêtes de fin
d'année
et vous qu'allez vous offrir à noël
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine nous vous
poserons la question l'occasion
peut-être de piocher quelques idées
parmi ces réponses a déjà des choses qui
vont faire plaisir on espère parfum
peut-être tout un cd un bouquet à mes
petites filles plutôt des habits pascal
bagnarol sont grandes à mon fils
également joffre
des chèques cadeaux les téléphones
portables pour mes petits enfants des
des playmobil pour les tout petits à ma
maman une robe de chambre alors pas de
jouer parce que j'ai plus de petits
enfants en bas âge